good evening police say they found an
explosive device not far from the las
vegas strip
thanks for joining us at six i'm denise
valdez and i'm bryan loftis it is a
story the i-team first broke earlier
today the i-team's vanessa murphy has
more now from
paradise and flamingo you can see how
busy the intersection here at flamingo
and paradise is
this is also just minutes from the las
vegas strip
and it's this area where metro police
say they found
christopher camacho driving around with
a homemade
explosive device in his car according to
this arrest report an
officer stopped camacho after he noticed
an excessive amount of smoke
coming from the exhaust on his honda
civic camacho
told the officer he was recently
released from prison
and there was a bb gun and fireworks in
his car
and he gave officers permission to
search it police say they found a black
pneumatic firearm and the homemade
explosive device
in the back seat the area was blocked
off and the bomb squad and
counterterrorism detectives were called
police determined a copper cylinder had
similar characteristics
to a manufactured explosive device and
powder in a clear tube was similar to
what's in commercial fireworks
investigators say they also found
equipment used for credit card fraud
they searched camacho's motel room on
boulder highway
according to the arrest report they
found equipment used for identity theft
and
credit card fraud in an interview police
say camacho told them he didn't intend
to hurt anyone
and he was going to light off what he
called a firework
in the desert with his son court records
show he faces two felony charges in
connection with the alleged explosive
device
and 11 counts in connection with
financial crimes
the nevada department of corrections
website reveals more about his
history it lists previous convictions
for a drug
charge stealing a car and having a gun
as a felon
camacho's next court date is set for
thursday
vanessa murphy 8 news now